Let's go next to our color from the nine Oh
nine area code.
Who is calling today from nine zero nine.
Hello, David?
Yes.
Hello.
Hi.
Um, okay.
Um, I have, I have a questions a little bit
different, other both, but, um, I would really
appreciate this information.
My main concern then that,
hold on a second.
You're, you're, you're breaking up.
Did you say your question is, or your name
is there was just a G the phone is just dropped
and we missed the, what sounded like a key
word there.
Okay.
Can you hear me now?
Yes.
Can you, okay.
My name is Ruth Ruth and, and my question
concerns voter tampering at the polls because
I feel like the polls are already rigged in
Donald Trump's favor.
And I feel like he knows this and that's one
of the reasons why he just kind of does whatever
he wants to do because what's the difference
he's going to win anyway.
And my question to you is this, okay.
Based on that, that premise, which I believe
is a fact, what can we do?
You know the voters, what, what can I do to
put a stop to this or to bring awareness to
this because what's the point of going down
these rabbit holes debating if Donald Trump
is going to win anyway because the polls are
already raved.
So here's my thought on this and I've, I've
been thinking about a lot about this for the
last six months or so, really, really longer.
Let's not even get into debating in what way
the polls are rigged or if they're regular.
Let's just concede that to some degree there
is going to be a combination of voter suppression
and messing with, and I mean even concede
messing with some voting machines.
Like let's say there's going to be some of
that.
There are two things that we can do before
the election.
What we can do is be activists.
Any time that there is an opportunity to push
back against the voter suppression technique
to push back against, you know, what's going
on in terms of irregularities with voting
machines.
In some places the voting machines being used
are being challenged.
Like let's do everything we can in advance.
But on election day, our turnout needs to
so overwhelm all of the foul play that the
foul play won't make a difference.
And in the end, if there's less foul play
than what we imagined there might be.
We just win by more.
But the foul play only works to some degree.
It works in States where it's close, it works
on the margins and they know that.
So they also need to depress the vote.
If we really get the vote out, we overwhelm
those tactics.
That's the reality.
So we've just, we've all got to go vote.
Oh my gosh, I feel so much better hearing
hat.
Right?
But we've got to go vote cause every, every,
every time.
It's the same thing, Ruth, where it's like
this time we're really, millennials are going
to vote and this and then it doesn't happen.
Right?
So we really need to overwhelm the vote.
That's the thing.
So the numbers from earlier this week in Mississippi
were turnouts up 70% but Republican turnouts
down 6% that's good.
That's what we need in 2020 but it's not a,
it's not a foregone conclusion.
Okay.
And you're sure that, um, what they have done
with the, um, the polling equipment, I hear
that.
I guess the Republicans are the ones who find
it.
You're pretty sure that that's not gonna just
change your boat automatically to Tom.
If vote for his opponent that I'm worried
about,
let's concede that that's going to happen
a little bit.
They can't give them California with that
technique, right?
I mean like, so this is what I'm saying, that
stuff.
W you can do it at the, at the precinct level
in States that are going to be close.
So we've got to counter it.
Let's assume it's going to happen and we've
got to counter it with overwhelming turnout.
Well, okay, then let's get out to vote.
That's right.
Okay.
Ruth, the pleasure of hearing from you.
I appreciate the call.
Yes, of course.
Thank you so much.
Feel free to call in again.
Great to hear from Ruth Ruth bringing some
energy.